>>Philip Jennings: Hi, You Tube. My name is
Philip Jennings. I am the general secretary
of Union Global Union, the world's largest
trade union.
The Davos conference is about to finish in
five minutes time and I thought it would be
a time to reflect on how do you judge the
success of this event in terms of working
people around the world? We represent working
people around the world. So I just thought
as a message to Claus and to Tony Blair, the
chairperson a message to them about how they
judge the success of this year through our
eyes.
First of all, we witnessed this week a financial
a mini financial meltdown and a kind of Davos
bounce. We've also had the world's biggest
banking fraud in France.
So therefore, first criteria: financial regulation.
Are the people here prepared to give financial
regulators the tools to ensure that the financial
wreckage that we've seen this week is brought
to an end? This is not business as usual.
If these things aren't changed then we consider
this Davos as being a damn ____.
Secondly, there's been a great deal of discussion
about poverty. Therefore, I'd like to suggest
that in one year's time we look at the share
of wages and the wealth produced by our nations
and then we can judge as to whether wages
have increased their share in national wealth
or not.
Most people here have been talking about poverty
reduction. Let's see if that is going to make
a difference in people's pocketbooks.
Another big theme in poverty reduction is
to give people decent work and jobs. Let's
look in one years' time and see if the number
of jobs has increased or the number of jobs
has decreased.
There's been a huge discussion here about
global citizenship, i.e., making businesses
good corporate citizens and they are going
to behave ethically and socially and so forth.
So let's see if multi-national companies are
prepared to sign a global agreement with global
unions like uni. There are 65 in the world
today. I would like to think with all the
great intentions expressed that by this time
next year we will have 100 global agreements
in place with trade unions around the world.
Private equity is here. We've brought them
out of the shadows and I'd like to see that
in the world of private equity they also begin
to pass the global citizenship test.
We've talked about poverty and health and
climate change. Let's see if carbon emissions
can actually be reduced during the course
of the next year.
When it comes to the great societal questions
of ill health and underdevelopment let's see
if the league table of the application of
the millennium development goals has actually
improved.
Bono made an appeal. Let's see if Bono's appeal
is actually being met.
Finally, a target that we have in the global
union movement and all of civil society is
that this is the 60th anniversary of the human
rights' declaration. We want people around
the world to stand up. We want to break the
Guinness Book of Records which is 43 million
people stood up last year for their rights.
This year we want 45 million people to stand
up for their rights.
So there we have it. A checklist for Claus,
a checklist for Tony Blair and the executive
board. I sincerely hope we make progress in
each of these areas, and if we do, I can assure
you the world will be a better place.
Thank you, You Tube. Over and out.